[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 pour un nouveau numéro de
municipal 2014 votre rendez-vous
politique pour tout savoir des
prochaines élections municipales dans
les Yvelines ce soir nous allons nous
pencher sur deux communes trappe avec la
candidature d'Otman nasrou soutenu par
l'UMP il se présente au nom d'un
collectif citoyen et puis tout d'abord
Alex Biet bonsoir vous êtes le maire UMP
de voisin le Bretonneux vous vous
présentez pour un nouveau mandat et la
campagne a déjà débuté pour vous vous
avez j'ai découvert votre page Facebook
vous avez lancé un compte facebook
alexibiat 2014 voilà tout à fait plus
sérieusement où on est l'élaboration un
petit peu de votre programme quel sera
votre planning pour les prochaines
semaines prochains mois alors il y a pas
que la candidature hein qui est c'est
vrai maintenant officiel mais c'est tout
un travail de préparation avec d'abord
les l'équipe en place on fait un on fait
un bilan et on décide de repartir
ensemble hein avec évidemment un
pourcentage de de renouvellement puisque
il y a des des personnes qui arrêtent
qui qui partent de la ville et vous la
souhaitz cette liste renouvelée pour
vivre et agir ensemble ça sera le nom de
votre liste et vous l'avez dit lorsque
vous avez annoncé votre candidature vous
voulez du renouvellement il faut des des
nouvelles têtes des nouvelles impulsions
pour pour cette ville de voisin bien sûr
c'est c'est pas le tout de continuer il
faut aussi
avoir bien des jeunes talents il faut
avoir des des idées
neuves il a je crois dans le prochain
mandat il faudra être très inventif pour
pouvoir continuer à maintenir euh les
services la qualité des services que
nous avons puisque vous le savez nous
sommes ponctionnés hein euh et donc on
nous avons moins de moyens financiers ça
veut dire qu'il y aura moins de
promesses pendant cette campagne euh
j'espère que en tout cas que ça sera
vraiment sous le saut de la du réalisme
euh et c'est vrai que là une une liste
j' dirais expérimentée hein
certainement sera plus réaliste que
d'autres en cas de victoire ce serait
votre 4e mandat il vous reste quoi à
accomplir sur cette commune vous savez
quand on aime on ne compte pas hein et
quand on a toujours bah c'est vrai la la
la foi l'envie de servir l'envie
de continuer à aménagerag aménager la
ville c'est pas c'est pas un problème et
puis quand il y a la santé aussi et
quels sont les grands projets qui vont
vous intéresser vous occuper sur cette
commune quelles sont les choses que vous
pensez ne pas encore avoir mené à leur
terme écoutez les les grands sujets hein
de de préoccupation et et d'action des
vcinoir c'est d'abord les
transports la circulation euh nous
sommes
trombosés tous les matins par la
circulation sud sud
Nord le deuxème sujet de préoccupation
c'est le
logement beaucoup de personnes
souhaiteraient installer à voisin
souhaiterait rester à voisin
souhaiterait aussi changer de logement
pour avoir un logement plus petit plus
fonctionnel et
malheureusement nous manquons de nous
manquons de logement ce renouvellement
de de la ville ça faisait aussi partie
des différents projets que vous avez
mené pendant les les précédents mandats
on peut parler peut-être du cœur
deeville 2011 une étude est lancée
l'enjeu c'est de fluidifier le secteur
on parlait déjà de transport et puis de
réaliser des logements aussi pour
endiguer cette chute démographique
aujourd'hui vous en êtes où et bien par
euh euh la modification du Plan
d'Occupation des Sols nous avons
autorisé la construction de logement
dans le centre-ville qui était euh dans
dans l'ancien plan d'occupation des sols
réservé à de l'activité qui n'avait plus
sa place vraiment dans dans un centre un
centre-ville et donc ça a fonctionné et
euh nous en sommes maintenant euh à la
3e opération après le jardin d'éline euh
villa aufleur et et le ma
et bien de renouvellement urbain avec
ces ces constructions heureusement que
nous avons ça et sur les autres
quartiers le quartier de la remise aussi
les travaux avanceent la situation
avance comment dans tous ces autres
quartiers où des projets ont été lancés
alors là c'est un peu plus long parce
que nous
travaillons avec la comité
d'agglomération de 5501 en yvline et je
dirais que voilà les les les étapes les
procédures sont vous nous expliquez que
les rapports sont compliqués avec la
communauté d'agglomération je je dis pas
je je je dis pas les rapports je dis que
l'agglomération est une grosse machine
euh et que c'est toujours plus long de
passer par la communé d'aglomération que
de passer directement avec des
propriétaires privé ou des promoteurs ça
veut dire que voisin va quitter la
communauté d'agglomération pour que les
choses aillent plus vite non vous nirez
pas jusque là non non non non non on va
on va transformer la comuné
d'agglomération donc vous misez sur une
victoire de la droite majoritairement
sur cquanttins en ieline tout à fa on
parle de votre commune de voisin
Bretonneux mais il y a un enjeu aussi
dans ces élections municipales ce serait
de voir basculer l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin puisquil y a quatre vill à
gauche trois à droite ce qui fait que le
rapport de force fait que la communauté
d'agglomération est à gauche vous pensez
que la droite peut l'emporter sur
Saint-Quentin en iveline il faudrait
qu'il y a une commune qui bascule et que
vous vous mainteniez dans chacune des
villes que vous possédez déjà alors
j'emploirai pas le même terme de de
basculement parce que quand vous dites
basculement ça veut dire qu'il y a deux
camps il y a un camp de droite un camp
de gauche et je crois très sincèrement
que l'avenir ne sera pas dans le
maintien de de ces camps et qu'on voudra
faire évoluer Saint-Quentin en Yveline
et qu'il y aura des accords de projets
puisque les villes ne seront plus
simplement représenté que par une seule
couleur politique mais avec une
représentation proportionnelle et donc
ça va changer je crois beaucoup de
choses quelle commune pourrait basculer
vous misez sur quelle commune même si je
garde ce terme de basculer et qu'il y
aurait de camp écoutez ça sera le
résultat de la campagne à venir je crois
que là vous allez recevoir un jeune qui
se présente sur qui se présente sur TR
alors qu' n'a pas l'investiture UMP
otman nasrou il est soutenu par la
droite et par le centre droit mais il
n'a pas l'investiture de l'UMP il ne l'a
pas souhaité il aura l'occasion de
s'expliquer tout à l'heure sur ça on va
rester sur la commune de voisin le
bretonne on en revient au scrutin de
2008 précédente élection triangulaire au
second tour vous obtenez 39,45 % devant
la liste de gauche de Jean h 31 % celle
de Joë Lenon divers droite 28 % et
quelques est-ce que le même scénario
pourrait se reproduire c'est possible
les deux hommes devraient être candidats
les choses devraient bouger dans les
prochains jours prochaines semaines il y
a une grande continuité dans les
fractures politiques qui reviennent tous
les 6 ans et c'est bien normal qu'il y
ait une liste de gauche quant à la liste
de droite elle est issue de la de ma
victoire en
1995 et c'est plus du ressenti person à
l'origine il y a même quatre listes lors
de ce scrutin là celle menée par André
deousa que je n'ai pas mentionné qui
était dissidente aussi qui vous Avaz
soutenu il y a eu un PCH sur votre
commune vous êtes resté en poste
finalement là c'est un scénario qui ne
vous inquiète pas comment vous allez
convaincre les vcinois comment vous
allez pouvoir agir sur ça et être
convainquant pour éviter encore une
triangulaire il y a pas d'alliance de
prévu non je je suis extrêmement serein
si vous voulez à partir du moment où il
y a un projet
où il y a une certaine crédibilité ce
sont les électeurs qui qui choisiront
moi ce que j'ai toujours souhaité c'est
le rassemblement c'est une liste très
large qui n'est pas basée vraiment sur
les courants politiques et d'ailleurs il
y a des gens de droite et de gauche sur
ma liste donc
prêueillir les opposants d'hier ser
auraient leur place sur votre liste mais
toute personne compétente qui souhait
s'investir sincèrement au service la
ville bien sûr elle est la bienvenue Jo
Lenon vous propose de se propose de vous
rejoindre ou Jean se propose de vous
rejoindre vous dites oui ah mais ça sera
discuté
maisé pas du tout pas du tout non non
non non s'il y a la compétence la
disponibilité la volonté de s'investir
au service de la ville il y a pas de
problème à quel moment vous allez
dévoiler cette liste pour le prochain
scrtin écoutez je suis en cours de la
constituer et donc j'père aboutir en en
octobre novembre voilà pour pouvoir
démarrer activement la la la campagne et
le contact avec les vissinois de sujets
pour conclure de sujets d'envergure
nationale mais qui concerern forcément
cette commune nous sommes le 3 septembre
rentrée scolaire réforme du temps
scolaire pour votre commune ce sera en
2014 vous êtes serein sur la mise en
place est-ce que vous avez déjà commencé
les consultations sur ce rythme scolaire
pour ces différentes écoles de votre vie
est-ce que ça peut être un enjeu de
campagne également alors on est
effectivement le jour de la de la
rentrée scolaire ce matin je suis passé
dans toutes dans toutes les écoles nous
déplorons malheureusement la fermeture
de trois classes hein pour un peu moins
d'une un peu moins de 20 20 20 enfants
moins euh c'est c'est beaucoup donc euh
les entre les annonces de postes
supplémentaires et la réalité je ne vois
pas concrètement euh ces postes là
arrivés en tout cas sur sur ma commune
et en ce qui concerne le rythme scolaire
c'est une chose vraiment
compliquée entre l'intérêt de
l'enfant l'INT l'intérêt de l'enfant qui
voudrait que on fasse un apprentissage 6
jours sur 7 l'intérêt des parents qui
eux souhaitent pouvoir régler je dirais
la vie scolaire sur la vie
professionnelle donc 5 jours sur 7 entre
l'intérêt des enseignants aussi qui eux
veulent peut-être le moins de
déplacement possible et bien c'est c'est
pas facile de choisir et donc nous avons
fait le choix de continuer à travailler
sur ce projetl et à mettre ça en place
en 2014 et surtout travailler sur le
projet éducatif territorial qui est
vraiment le le côté le plus intéressant
de la réforme pour pouvoir mettre tout
le monde en accord sur un projet commun
il faudra agir vite l'inspection
académique AJ déjà prévenu qu'il
faudrait rendre la copie de travail
avant la fin de l'année he pour
justement se préparer à une éventualité
qui sont les municipales 2014 qui
pourrait faire pasasculer ou rendre
compliqué les différentes prises de
décisions dans les dans les villes nous
avons des groupes de travail qui vont
réunir les parents d'élèves les
enseignants la municipalité les services
municipaux les associations et qui vont
démarrer là ce mois-ci et puis le tout
dernier sujet une dernière réaction
c'était le concernant le mariage
homosexuel vous étiez contre vous
appliquez la loi dans votre commune
aujourd'hui bien sûr ça peut être un
enjeu de campagne là aussi est-ce que ça
va jouer tous ces faits de société tous
ces changements au niveau nationale
est-ce que ça peut empiéter sur la la
campagne sur la réforme scolaire le
mariage
homosexuel la réforme scolaire peut-être
euh le mariage homosexuel non c'est
quelque chose je crois de de très intime
de très personnel je ne pense pas en
tout cas moi je suis légaliste hein
malgré euh le le peu de de cas qui a été
fait de de nos avis hein et donc il n'y
aura pas de problème à voisin vous avez
célébré des mariages depuis la
promulgation de la loi non pas encore
pas encore merci Alexis Biette maire UMP
de voisin le bretonux candidat un
nouveau mandat en mars prochain
municipal 2014 se poursuit dans un
instant otman nasrou candidat soutenu
par la droite et le centre il porte une
liste citoyenne àrappe on s'écarte pour
l'instant des municipales on se penche
sur les Européens le scrutin pour
désigner nos députés au Parlement à
Strasbourg se déroulera aussi en 2014
fin mai la conseillère générale des
ivelines Christine Boutin annonce
qu'elle sera candidate vous allez la
voir lors d'une séance du conseil
général au lendemain de l'annonce de sa
démission de la présidence du parti
chrétien-démocrate elle dit vouloir
poursuivre son action contre le mariage
pour tous en préparant des listes pour
ce prochain scrutin au côté de Béatrice
bourge autre figure de l'opposition au
mariage gay elle aussi d'ailleurs
installée dans les ivelines alors
pourquoi les Européennes et avec quelles
ambitions nous lui avons poser la
question les européennes c'est des
élections particulières c'est pas la
proximité c'est pas comme la municipale
ou même la législative ou même la
présidentielle c'est au mois de juin de
l'année prochaine donc nous avons le
temps mais nous allons alimenter notre
réflexion je suis dans l'affiliation
dans l'héritage de Robert Schuman avec
sa dimension politique et spirituelle de
reste et et nous voulons que l'homme la
personne humaine la vie la vie elle est
ni de droite ni de gauche c'est notre
patrimoine et c'est notre bien commun or
aujourd'hui la vie vie a perdu son sens
nous ne savons plus pourquoi nous sommes
là sinon pour l'argent pour le fric on a
l'impression que on nexiste qu'en qu'en
fonction de cette valeur monétaire en ce
qui concerne les les listes il y aura
une liste portant le même label qui est
du reste à définir dans les h
circonscriptions européennes je serai
candidate ça c'est
certain et puis un proche de Christin
Bouttin a lui aussi démissionné au début
de l'été non pas du Parti chrétien
déémocrate mais de son poste de
conseiller municipal à Montini le
breteneux Mathieu Colombani reste
délégué général du PCD il ne siège plus
au côté de Michel logier lui aussi
engagé contre le mariage pour tous il
lutte à présent contre l'engagement
français en Syrie sur le plan local on
devrait le retrouver sur une liste dans
une commune de droite pour les
municipales c'est en tout cas lui qui
nous l'a dit récemment qu'il l'a
annoncé
deè invité de ce numéro de municipal
2014 otman nasrou bonsoir vous êtes le
président de trappe citoyen candidat à
la mairie de trappe vous avez 26 ans
jeunes candidat donc et à la tête d'une
liste soutenue par l'UMP le modem et
l'UDI j'ai bien dit soutenu vous n'avez
pas l'investiture vous ne la souhaitez
pas cette investiture je n'ai souhaité
demander l'investiture d'aucun parti
parce que je considérais que la
situation attrape et puis le projet que
j'avais envie de porter qui est le fruit
de mon expérience à la fin dans le monde
associé iniatif aussi en tant que chef
d'entreprise c'était pas un projet qui
méritait d'être enfermé juste dans les
frontières d'un parti moi le le clivage
droite gauche traditionnel il peut me
mettre mal à l'aise sur le plan local je
suis pas sûr qu'il ait beaucoup de sens
aujourd'hui à trppe les enjeux qu'on
connaît à trape sont c'est l'emploi la
sécurité l'éducation et là-dessus
j'avais envie d'être le candidat de
toute l'opposition de tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans les idées concrètes
que j'ai envie de proposer aux habitants
de la ville et puis voilà nous rejoétip
par exemple c'est pas un handicap
lorsqu'on est candidat sur trappe je
pense pas que ce soit une un handicap
parce que je pense que les gens vraiment
que ce soit l'UMP ou le Parti socialiste
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment plus le sujet
ça qu'atrape il y a une énorme
abstention les gens vraiment le
sentiment que il ne contrôle plus les
décisions qui les concernent directement
l'aménagement de la ville sur les
aspects d'éducation et on l'a vu avec
l'application de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires attrape contre la vie des
parents d'élèves et des enseignants
alors aujourd'hui en cette rentrée on
peut espérer que les choses vont
s'améliorer progressivement mais c'est
vrai que ça a été un moment de
cristallisation et on a vu que droite ou
gauche c'était plus vraiment le sujet en
tout cas vous ne cachez pas être de
droite vous êtes plutôt F ioniste
d'ailleurs et puis il y a une tribune
aussi dans l'Express sur Internet qui a
été publiée fin 2012 que vous aviez
rédigé est intitulé être jeune et de
droite ce n'est pas une situation
confortable ou tout à fait vous nêtes
pas à l'aise à l'UMP vous n'êtes pas à
l'aise à droite moi je suis comme je
vous le disais je suis effectivement de
centre droit je suis proche d'une partie
de la droite goulis je suis attaché à
cet héritage là je considère que sur le
plan des valeurs je crois au mérite je
crois au travail je crois en l'autorité
voilà j'aimerais que chacun a sa chance
et que les meilleurs puissent aussi
réussir grâce à leur travail donc je
suis attaché à toutes ces valeurs là
après comme je vous le disais je me
méfie des partis politiques je considère
que soit à droite ou à gauche les partis
politiques sont des appareils qui ont
tendance à confisquer le débat à
étouffer les choses on a trop de
carriéristes dans les partis politiques
donc voilà tout simplement candidature
elle est plus large elle est soutenue je
le revendique complètement par l'UMP
l'UDI le modem c'est-à-dire par
l'ensemble des formations d'opposition
donc je suis le candidat de toute
l'opposition d'une opposition citoyenne
avec des trapistes qui sont aussi des
sympathisants de gauche et avec lesquels
je m'entends très bien et qui partage
beaucoup de mes valeurs donc je n'ai pas
de raison de m'enfermer derrière
l'investiture dernière liste au
municipal précédente municipale qui
s'était présenté de cette manière avec
un soutien des partis de droite mais
sans investiture elle était menée par
Gérard Fourgous le frère du maire
d'élancour d'ailleurs il a depuis
démissionné il avait récolté 8,57 % des
voix au premier tour avec une élection
de guimalandin à 80 % le socialiste
pourquoi vous allez pouvoir faire mieux
alors je suis pas sûr de vos résultats
parce qu'il me semble que c'est pas
vraiment ça vous parlez pe-être
desincrits mais au premier tour le
résult éta de 16 % pour Gérard forgous
mais peu importe toute façon
effectivement on va pas chipoter sur les
chif c'est pas très intéressant Gérard
frogou c'était un candidat indépendant
c'est c'était présenté comme ça moi je
revendique d'être un candidat de
l'opposition je suis en désaccord
profond avec l'équipe municipale
actuelle et je suis soutenu je très
clairement par l'UMP l'UDI et le modem
ça me pose aucun problème j'en suis
extrêmement fier et je les remercie de
la confiance qu'il m'apporte voilà
maintenant simplement sur le plan des
idées qu'est-ce que ça voudrait dire un
projet UMP ou un projet PS d'ailleurs
sur trap les sujets qu'on a aujourd'hui
à trap on a une énorme priorité sur
l'éducation est-ce que c'est pas un
sujet qui est de droite ou de gauche
l'éducation on peut pas continuer à
avoir attrape l'échec scolaire qu'on a
est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui le
nécessaire à trrappe pour que les
enfants puissent pour que les parents
puissent élever leurs enfants dans les
meilleures conditions très sincèrement
sur tous ces sujetsl il faut créer un
consensus pour vous l'équipe en place
l'équipe en place depuis plusieurs
années celle menée par guimalandin n'a
pas répondu aux attentes de la
population c'est ce que vous bah si je
pensais que tout allait bien à traape je
serais pas candidat non je pense qu'il y
a des tas de sujets qui sont pas traités
on faitcou vousêtes arrivé il y a 3 ans
sur cette commune tout à fait tout à
fait tout à fait comme beaucoup de
trapistes je suis pas né j'ai pas grandi
à trape j'ai choisi de m'y installer à
la fin de mes études je c'est une ville
que j'ai prise en affection petit à
petit je me suis engagé je suis passé
notamment par le collectif trap citoyen
mon beaucoup d'opérations sur sur
l'entrepreneuriat en permettant à des
jeunes de suivre une formation pour
apprendre à créer leur entreprise sur le
logement social notamment avec les
difficultés qu'il y a avec certains
bailleurs qui sont malhonnêtes et
là-dessus c'est vrai que les beaucoup de
trapistes sont laissés un peu sont un
peu désœuvrés donc sur tous ces sujets
là je suis vraiment pas sûr que la
question aujourd'hui soit savoir droite
ou gauche VO tout cas votre liste est
finalisée pas encore alors notre liste
est constituée on lance un appel à tous
ceux qui veulent nous rejoindre on on
fera l'annonce précise de la
constitution de la liste avec vous le
verrez des gens qui sont de sensibilité
extrêmement divers c'est pas c'est parce
que le projet qu'on doit mettre en place
aujourd'hui à trap c'est pas le projet
d'un parti il faut qu'on arrive à
dépasser complètement cela sinon on va
encore repartir sur des années où ne se
passera rien d'essentiel pour les
habitants de trappe parce que s'occuper
de la pierre comme on le fait à traape
depuis des années c'est bien mais il y a
un momentù va falloir s'occuper des gens
et à traape la réalité sociale elle est
restée la même alors vous évoquez cette
rénovation urbaine beaucoup de choses
ont changé des quartiers ont été
totalement remaniés sur cette ville de
trappe ça n'est pas suffisant cette
rénovation urbaine alors même l'annonce
de la couverture puisque ça a été fait
on en a parlé lors du rendez-vous
d'actualité de de la rédaction de la
couverture de la National 10 ce plateau
urbain 400 m pour couvrir la National 10
là aussi c'est une avancée c'est
présenté comme une avancée aussi pour la
population pour vous ça n'est pas
suffisant moi je suis pas dans
l'opposition systématique je suis pas là
pour faire de la politique politicienne
c'est quelque chose qui me fatigue voilà
c'est peut-être encore naïveté de mon
âge mais voilà je suis pas là pour ça
donc quand il y a des choses qui sont
bonnes je je le dis je pense
qu'effectivement ce qui a ét entrepris
sur trap sur le plan urbain ce sont des
bonnes choses et c'était certainement
nécessaire ça s'imposit est-ce que
maintenant c'est suffisant est-ce que ça
détermine ce qu'on doit faire désormais
moi je ne le pense pas je pense que
maintenant la question je vous le dis
c'est avant tout l'éducation parce que
là-dessus on a des gros problèmes donc
on peut aménager la indice c'est quelque
chose dont on parle depuis depuis depuis
30 ans donc contant qu'on envoie le bout
le maire actuel d'ailleurs est en charge
de ce dossierlà depuis 20 ans quand même
il faut le rappel différcage lié aussi à
Laé aussi au gouvernement au changement
de majorité comme par hasard 6 mois
avant l'élection on en fait une annonce
c'est très bien je peux comment
féliciter je ne peux comment félicité
vous avez raison de le rappeler donc
tant mieux si les conivences des uns et
des autres permettent sur le terrain une
avancée de la situation mais sur le fond
c'est pas ça qui va améliorer le
quotidien destrapis c'est un peu facile
alors l'ication justement cette réforme
la réforme scolaire c'est une bonne
réforme une mauvaise réforme elle est en
vigueur depuis ce matin sur la ville de
TR alors c'est une réforme
gouvernementale donc on a pas le choix
il faut l'appliquer mais simplement je
regrette qu'on l' appliqué en 2013 je
pense que ça a été une grave erreur il y
a communes dans les ivelines qui l'ont
appliqué sur 240 quand même c'est moins
de 3 % des villes je pense et traape est
la plus grosse ville à l'avoir appliqué
je pense qu'on a sacrifié nos enfants
là-dessus c'est une réforme qui doit
être préparée qui doit se faire dans la
concertation et on se souvient dans
quelles condition quand même cette
décision a été prise contre la vie des
parents d'élèves contre les les
enseignants et très sincèrement si
c'était une bonne chose je le dirais
mais on a des activités périscolaires
qui sont mal défin est-ce que les
activités qui sont proposées aujourd'hui
sont celles qui permettent aux enfants
de trapppe de réussir le mieux possible
j'en doute fort est-ce que les horaires
qui sont proposés sont intelligent ça ne
me paraît pas évident avec des horaires
alombiqués 8h50 11h si vous êtes élu par
exemple vous changeriez tout ça oui il
faut absolument le remettre à PL et
notamment sur les contenus on doit se
poser la question notre projet éducatif
att trp on l'a pas fait on a décidé
d'appliquer cette réforme pour des motif
politique bon pour le coup des motifs
politiciens même j'assume le terme mais
pour les enfants de trappe c'est pas du
tout une bonne réforme en l'état voilà
donc oui il faudra la remettre à plat
avec les parents d'élèves et les
enseignants et surtout proposer des des
choses qui permettent aux élèves
vraiment de mieux réussir à l'école et
quelle réponse vous apportez pour
conclure à ces jeunes qui sont en
difficulté qu'on a pu voir
malheureusement à l'antenne durant l'été
avec toutes ces émeutes qui se sont
produits à l'issue d'un contrôle de
police d'une jeune femme qui portait le
le voile intégral quelle réponse vous le
pouvez leur apporter alors déjà je pense
pas que ce soit forcément les mêmes je
veux dire l'ensemble des jeunes de
trappe quasi totalité ce sont pas des
jeunes qui brûlent des voitures ce sont
pas des jeunes voilà c'est bon de le
préciser on est d'accord je fais pas ce
procès là mais c'est toujours bon de le
préciser parce que c'est vrai que dans
les médias c'est pas toujours évident
puis on a eu une image très dégradée de
la ville à cause de ces événements sur
les jeunes qui sont en difficulté
d'accès à l'emploi il il faut énormément
de volonté politique et c'est des sujets
sur lesquels à titre personnel je j'y
suis très sensible par mon mon parcours
donc il se trouve que avec le collectif
trape citoyen ça fait longtemps qu'on
est sur le terrain depuis maintenant un
peu plus d'une année pour monter des
opérations on propose effectiv des
stages tout simplement une base de
données de stage sur la ville il me
semble que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important du coaching pour
les pour les jeunes qui veulent s'en
sortir en leur permettant du tutorat
avec des élèves par exemple de grandes
écoles c'est des choses qu'on a proposé
et qu'on a proposé à la municipalité
actuelle qui ont pas malheureusement pas
été retenu donc il y a il y a des tas de
choses qu'on peut imaginer sur le sur
sur l'école il y a le soutiens scolaire
il faut absolument un dispositif de
soutien scolaire vraiment adapté
pourquoi pas étudier la possibilité
d'avoir des classes de niveau parce que
aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement le cas
il y a une petite minorité d'élèves qui
perturbe le fonctionnement de de de
beaucoup de nos écoles att trp donc
surtout tous ces sujetsl il faut une
vraie volonté il faut y aller vraiment à
fond parce que vraent le plus important
ression pas de répression alors après
sur la question des violences vous
m'interrogez sur la question de
l'insertion professionnelle ce qui est
un point essentiel sur la question des
violences la loi la vocation être
appliquée par tout le monde et moi je ne
comprends pas qu'on puisse accepter ou
dire qu'il y a des raisons et cetera
quel que soit le fait divers quel que
soit y compris le comportement de la
police parce que je ne dis pas qu'il
peut y avoir des problèmes de dialogue
avec les forces de l'ordre rien n'excuse
la violence rien n'excuse qu'on ait des
voitures brûlées et j'aimerais dire que
ce sont les voitures des gens de Trapp
les bâtiments des trapistes nos
installations nos impôts qui les
financent donc ça c'est inacceptable et
ça ne doit plus jamais se reproduire la
seule réponse c'est la fermeté ça veut
pas dire qu'il n'y a pas des problèmes
sous-jacents avec la police les deux
réponses en tout cas c'est ce que vous
nous dites ce que vous nous expliquez
toute dernière question vous avez fondé
une société en 2010 tout à fait citizen
place si vous êtes maire vous ferez les
deux activités ah bah écoutez je pense
que ça me laissera moins le temps de
m'occuper de mon entreprise mais par
qu'on est un jeune entrepreneur on a du
temps aussi pour une pour une
municipalité et ben écoutez moi j'ai
toujours été l'engagé vous avez par C
entreprise qui une entreprise à vocation
sociale puisquelle l'outil le monde
associatif avec des outils informatiques
donc moi c'est c'est mon parcours donc
je m'adonnerai évidemment la fonction de
maire à à plein temps matin midi et soir
parce que c'est une mission essentielle
et qu'aujourd'hui il y a tellement à
faire sur trap de côté votre société je
laisserai de côté bien entendu si c'est
si les trapistes me font confiance merci
Hotman asrou président de trappe citoyen
candidat sur cette ville de trappe merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau dernière
information concernant les municipal à
morpa il est toujours aussi difficile
d'y voir claair qui va représenter l'UMP
en mars dans cette ville le qui lui est
plutôt à gauche sur leschquier politique
George Mougeot pourrait voir son premier
adjoint de l'UDI pierre leguerinel se
présenter avec ce soutien de l'UMP
seulement quelqu'un d'autre a demandé
l'investiture c'est Grégory garestier
adhérant à l'UMP proche du maire
d'élancour Jean-Michel forous il vient
même de faire son entrée au conseil
municipal en raison de la démission d'un
autre membre de l'opposition et il se
présente comme le candidat officiel de
ce parti de droite deux homme pour une
seule investiture reste à voir comment
les instances locales vont réussir à
trancher ce dossier quand Thomer lui a
décidé annoncer ou non sa nouvelle
candidature pas avant le mois de janvier
fin de ce numéro de municipal 2014
prochain rendez-vous politique sur TVfil
dans 15 jour et puis bien sûr les
dernières informations chaque jour dans
le 78 actu à 18h excellente
[Musique]
soirée